what do you get when you cross a
mentally ill loner in this society that
abandons him and treats them like trash
I'll tell you what you get 11 Oscar
nominations and you're in the Mortal
Kombat 11 combat pack what we're gonna
cover this Joker official gameplay
trailer starring Joaquin that's right
they're taking the Arthur Fleck version
which is totally appropriate ever more
important in Mortal Kombat's you're
finishing movies drop blood smiles wow
they're like hey they're filming what I
do do I look lights now hear hear yeah
can we get on a ladder and go to the
window
[Music]
start to talk with that lips Oh a
wheelchair
[Applause]
[Music]
I love that there it is
here it is
[Music]
you didn't finish
damn straight he does can't wait to play
this Toni guilt reesy I know you're
watching I will be coming over actually
I got an I have a ps4 Xbox one
you're coming over here we're fighting
each other buddy I never have excited
house never have to leave I don't like
leaving I don't like stepping outside
pride now have you seen they're on each
other
Netflix special oh my god it's so good
if you guys haven't seen that you gotta
watch it anyway we're not talking about
that this was great I love it I love how
they have majorly amplified how much
shenanigans he does now that are so
clown comical there's some like really
truly weird random stuff here studying
in the hostage I thought was great
oh it looks like he's pulling some dude
out of a wheelchair too and just like
beating you with it and then it explodes
a little Batman will pop it the puppet
the puppet with the gun and it's back in
the box the boxing gloves on the springs
I love although random is there and then
on the fatality move when he beats it
hammer like how he couch ocher killed
Jason Todd you gotta go or didn't
successfully kill him a B Jason Todd I
don't know who voices the Joker here it
doesn't sound like it's Mark Hamill but
it sounds like a guy who's aiming for
the Mark Hamill voice yeah I'm satisfied
with it I think what everyone's gonna be
you know hoping for is one day you do
get hurt there's like it's like he
wouldn't fit but no to every like really
look at the character of Arthur but but
we're gonna want to see the Joker
version maybe he can do some fatality
where he brings him to a talk show then
shoot her you know well you know I mean
we watched that video a little while
back that was that animated Joker fight
between Heath Ledger Joaquin Phoenix
from my direction yeah yeah yeah so you
know seeing that
okay I can understand how that would
maybe work he would just have to be the
most mellow Mortal Kombat container yeah
and then when you play a same everyone
will be wondering was this all in his
head the whole time maybe this is real I
mean I'm always impressed by the
inventiveness
of the violence and oddly this felt like
the most violent one out of all the
eleven promos I've seen just for how
brutal especially the finishing move is
with the stabs and the Chelsea smile and
all that stuff one thing I've noticed is
that their sound design is these games
thrown that's exactly what I was about
yeah harp on i really suggest watching
this trailer with headphones guys that's
a big part of what makes it sound much
more brutal I think I mean right it's
generally for Mortal Kombat videos but I
think with the head blows of the weapons
of the Joker has just hear that yeah
like yeah like a big mallet or something
makes and you like it makes it hurt that
much more and the blood goo effects you
know the sounds that come with that so
great so great alright guys well are you
excited for this comment below use your
negative thoughts to hit that subscribe
button if you used to think your life
was a tragedy hit that like button but
if you now realize your life is a comedy
click that notification bell I should
have rearranged the order and thought
that out little who's laughing now let's
do a patron of the day shout out I feel
like we're gonna open that window we're
just gonna see the guy just blowing it
right hurt a lot
you got it on but he's got his face
press yeah he can see the Mortal Kombat
let's get a page to the day shout out to
a woman named Victoria Huntley now
Victoria I don't know when you're
getting married but you're supposed to
be getting married soon I imagine I
think that it would be great if you and
your hubby can cosplay as Joker and
Harley Quinn and if he does something
that defies the vows of marriage
you can do all these Mortal Kombat 11
moves on him and you know would it be a
fun way to get some revenge use these
games as inspiration that's what they're
for there to inspire real action in life
that's what movies and games do and I
think you got a heart beyond that in
your real-life relationship unless he's
imaginary you know like in the movie